the jurogan experience who knew who
michael keaton was when beetlejuice came
out
here's a comic and he was on a
television show before that
really yeah yeah michael keaton was on a
sitcom
um trying to think of what it was mister
something
right hmm mr big is that a thing god
damn it i don't remember
but it was a sitcom working working
what was it about stiffs working stiffs
um he was uh a stand-up he was on
evening at the improv
yeah he's got a big neon at the comedy
store
does it all's fair and the married title
are more our it says
hmm yeah he was around for a while and
you know there's a lot of people that
are really reluctant
to accept him as batman
hilarious because he's kind of like this
thin guy
he doesn't it's not jacked
might have been the best batman ever
without a doubt might have been the best
batman
no question about and that's including
christian bale yeah
not only was he the best batman he was
also the best bruce wayne
believable glasses tip of his nose
researching
you know they all had a stupid fake
voice though
there he is oh batman's had a [ __ ]
fake voice
did you see the founder well it's being
considered for a batman role
there's a tv i think he was going to be
on the tv show
who's he going to be like i don't know
batman there's like a tv show uh oh
the flag he is going to pop up in the
flash i think is what i heard
wow he is in talks to play batman
that's crazy this was in the summer they
talked about it
wow we see her using an ad blocker
chairman
backlash um who is the worst batman
the least believable clooney ben affleck
yeah clooney bennett affleck ah well
yeah okay
both of them how about that i think
affleck has to take it but
i don't know affleck's doing it still
that's the problem really
yeah oh god they're doing a new movie
now now flex batman again
i just he's ben affleck he's not batman
he's ben affleck i don't not like ben
affleck i like ben affleck
but that's bad that's not bad they also
have the uh
guy from uh twilight is gonna be him too
right oh yes
pattinson yeah yeah again that's the guy
from twilight oh that's not batman
affleck is taking
uh michael keaton's spot in the flash so
like a month later they announced
affleck's gonna be him
so who knows they need a new guy
you need a new guy who's jacked
right me after i get on testosterone
you're gonna need a few years i could be
robin now though
you could the the original one it's so
funny
because the bat there was like the
batman comic books
that were very 1950s right that sort of
style and then there was uh the batman
um those illustrated books
what do they call those graphic novels
the graphic novels are very different
because then
the graphic novel novels it was very
dark and very like really cool
really well drawn and like heavy duty
[ __ ] like he's a different batman
like batman was jacked and you know
there's like
a lot of like serious uh story lines and
a lot of heavy duty [ __ ]
now that was the batman that sort of
existed
in that that was the dark knight that
was uh like the christian braille
batman that kind of made sense but
the original batman for tv was
ridiculous look at him
like look how he's dressed everything
jeremiah after the weight gain challenge
the dude looked like he never worked out
he had this ridiculous belt on
he had silly shorts on the cape
like the show was so dumb like look at
his muscles they're non-existent
wow he's look at the even the suit it's
like so campy and corny but it was that
way on purpose
like when you punch guys you'd see like
a bam in front of the screen do you
remember batman
you're too young i would yeah did you
watch it at all yeah it would like play
on the
adult swim around
batman yeah it was so
so corny jeez it was so
campy and corny but that's what it was
and then when they went to michael
keaton like that movie was very
different like it was like brooding and
then
when you get to keith heath ledger and
heath ledger's playing batman he was the
joker [ __ ] excuse me the joker
when he was playing the joker against
batman rather you're getting this
like violent weird
sort of character that is interacting
with
batman and taking over the city there's
half face
literally half his face is [ __ ]
seared off incredible han zimmer stepped
it up on that one too the music music mr
freeze
wow the freeze meister wow who's he
supposed to be what's
yeah it's mr freeze that's the name yeah
yeah yeah
those are terrible that was the clooney
one right
yes that was like let's get as many
famous people as we can in a movie
yeah let's just throw as much [ __ ]
against the walls we can see what sticks
right there actually jim carrey was
michelle pfeiffer in that too
uh yeah she was poisoned no that was the
one before she was in the michael keaton
one where she was a
bat catwoman member is that george
clooney
yes he looks good oh he's a good batman
it's weird
they totally redid this the suit like
they gave him some fake abs
fake titties it's it's
very odd catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify you can listen to
the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience